who's god
all those gods the stories they've been
told throughout history you said through
the spiritual traditions
what do you think that is is that us
trying to find that
common
thing at the core
well in in many
traditions not all
the one i was raised in so my dad was a
protestant minister
we tend to think of god
as a being
but i think that
that's not right
i think
the closest way to think about god is
being period not a being but
being
the very ground of being itself is god i
think that's the
the deep and from my point of view
that's the ground of consciousness so
the ground of conscious being is
what we might call god but but the word
god has always been you know for example
you don't believe the same god as my god
so i'm going to fight you or i will
we'll have wars over because
the being the specific being that you
call god is different from the being
that i call god and so we fight whereas
if it's
not a being but just being and you and i
share being then you and i are are not
separate and there's no reason to fight
we're both part of that one being and
and
loving you is loving myself because
we're all part of that one being
the spiritual traditions that point to
that
i think are pointing
it in a very interesting direction and
that does seem to
match with the mathematics of the
conscious agent stuff that i've been
working on as well that
it really fits with that although that
wasn't my goal
you